this video was made possible by
brilliant learn complex topic simply
with brilliant for 20% off by being one
of the first 200 to sign up at brilliant
org slash went over nearly ten years ago
in the mid afternoon of January 12 2010
a magnitude 7.0 earthquake hit just
outside port-au-prince Haiti leveling a
large part of the country and killing an
unimaginable number of people in a quick
30 seconds it immediately became clear
that although the earthquake lasted only
seconds the humanitarian disaster would
last for years because of three simple
facts one was the earthquakes location
in a twist of terrible luck the quake
hits shallow and just 60 miles for 25
kilometers away from the country's
capital and largest city port-au-prince
- was Haiti's economic situation it is
the poorest country in the Western
Hemisphere with an estimated GDP per
capita at the time of the earthquake of
just 665 dollars that meant that most
Haitians had little money to relocate
and reestablish their lives after their
homes were destroyed in addition with a
poorly funded government emergency
services were few and far between and
poorly equipped the third fact leading
to the scale of the humanitarian
disaster was just the pure scale of
destruction most buildings in the island
nation were not nearly as stable as
those in a developed nation and
therefore whereas another developed
country might have been able to weather
the quake quite well the buildings of
Haiti crumbled like dust with the scale
of destruction as soon as word of the
quake reached the rest of the world the
focus of every major disaster response
organization in the world shifted to
Haiti the whole world of disaster
response is a nuanced and complex one
simply showing up and helping where one
can just doesn't work
water isn't useful by itself food isn't
useful by itself doctors aren't useful
by themselves every resource that might
be needed following a disaster must be
carefully coordinated and managed or
else it is useless behind that
management there are professionals who
spend their whole lives working on how
to best respond to moments like these
the worst 30 seconds
of Haiti's history I spoke to two of
those professionals on how they do their
jobs
Stephanie Kayden I am a vice chair of
emergency medicine at Brigham and
Women's Hospital and the director of the
humanitarian studies initiative in Mike
van Ryan I'm the director of the Harvard
humanitarian initiative and I'm a
professor at the Harvard Medical School
in the School of Public Health
both Stephanie and Mike helped establish
and then worked on the ground at would
became one of the largest field
hospitals in Haiti following the 2010
earthquake it turns out that when you're
a doctor responding to one of these
international disasters just having
medical knowledge is not good enough in
order to do this work properly you have
to know what the international standards
are for giving humanitarian aid you have
to know not only the medical side but
how to give food and how to give clean
water and how to give proper shelter and
those guidelines are already written
down in something called the sphere
standards in its 406 pages the sphere
handbook has specific guidelines like
that everyone needs 15 litres of water
per day that a single hand pump at a
flow rate of 17 liters per minute can
act as the water source for up to 500
people it gives a clear step-by-step
guide to establishing a goods delivery
system it defines that in an emergency
shelter situation everyone should have
at least 38 square feet or 3.5 square
meters of living space but that in cold
climates that should be increased to 48
square feet or 4.5 square meters it
takes out as much of the guesswork in
humanitarian response as possible this
is what much of the work by academics
like Stephanie and Mike is developing
standards and frameworks before a
disaster happens so that as much as
possible when disaster strikes people
don't need to think they just need to do
this response does of course though vary
depending on the nature of the disaster
an earthquake tends to cause a lot of
death immediately and also a lot of
heavy injuries like fractures or head
injuries they are intensive they require
intensive medical care and surgical care
they overwhelm the the hospital
structures as well and so the immediate
needs for a place like Haiti for example
our surgeons
people who could manage emergency wound
care and even things like dialysis or
things like that that that these crush
injuries happened and they also require
a lot of rehabilitation let's take an
other example of say a flood right a
flood can be amazingly devastating move
people out of their house even sweep
people away but a flood or a hurricane
kills people but doesn't necessarily
leave a lot of injured people so at the
end after people have died from a
massive flood or a hurricane what's left
are people who have minor injuries maybe
but they don't really overwhelm the
surgical structures of a hospital what
they overwhelmed is the public health in
an ideal world the level of humanitarian
aid given would be determined by the
actual need but in reality this is often
not the case the reality is that often
but not always the more accessible a
disaster site is the more response it
gets what that means is that because
Haiti was so close to the US where many
humanitarian organizations are based it
was quite easy for them to mobilize
after this earthquake so Haiti got large
numbers of responders quite quickly but
this principle can also leave other
countries without the help they need so
take for example around the same time as
the Haiti earthquake there was a massive
flood in Pakistan but it was very remote
and very difficult to get to so the the
difference in the responders is entirely
different the only people that could
respond in this distant area of Pakistan
for this massive flood were the major
organizations that had lifting capacity
and they could fly planes and they could
land personnel in in the middle of
someplace it's very remote Haiti on the
other hand received a massive response
especially in comparison by smaller
organizations given the proximity to the
US and also given the fact that
individuals in the US were particularly
motivated to donate given the proximity
through NGOs and charities Americans
contributed about four billion dollars
to the relief effort in the first three
months therefore the real issue in Haiti
was not getting a response it was
managing the response because of that
accessibility from the US a huge number
of less professional responders showed
up
and in order to be effective these
responders needed a high degree of
management from the professionals who
did show up and were practiced on the
international standards in addition
there was the issue of actually getting
all these responders and their supplies
there in the case of Haiti it's an
island nation so a lot of the heavy
things like fuel have to come in by ship
but the earthquake severely damaged the
port in port-au-prince and because the
gas stations with their underground
tanks had also been damaged the relief
community couldn't use the fuel from
those tanks without ruining the engines
in their cars and shutting down all the
the trucks and so there was a big fuel
crisis early on and that meant it was
hard to transport things so while we
were waiting for the port to be fixed a
lot of the supplies had to be flown in
either on airplanes that were landing at
the port-au-prince Airport or overland
from the Dominican Republic in the early
days of the response both of these
methods have their own unique
difficulties coming from the Dominican
Republic
many of these roads were damaged
destroyed or covered in debris so that
was quite a slow option the airport
therefore stood alone as the only
high-speed link between Haiti and the
world serving as the only route in for
all the most time-sensitive supplies in
the initial 24 hours after the
earthquake port-au-prince his airport
saw chaos as flight poured in with no
direction into an airport with
essentially no control the first
semblance of control came the morning
after the quake when the US Coast Guard
Cutter forward pulled into
port-au-prince and just hours later
started working as the airport's air
traffic control from the ship the
airport's own air traffic control tower
was badly damaged in the quake so it was
far from operational soon after that
same afternoon a team of US Air Force
Airmen landed at the airport and assumed
responsibility for its air traffic
control their operation was made up of
quite literally a bunch of folding
tables and handheld radios set up at the
end of the runway as they guided flights
in with this setup they handled up to
almost 200 planes a day despite the fact
that only a normal day the airport
received no more than a dozen commercial
flights eventually Haiti officially
handed control of the airport over to
the US
meaning the Americans could settle in
and set up formally for the long haul
and a team from the American FAA came
down to take control as they set up a
portable temporary air traffic control
tower of course even working at full
capacity there was still an enormous
backlog at this small airport leading
them to set up a system where flight
will be prioritized based off what they
carried with the highest demand
humanitarian goods being allowed in
first of course even once you get a
plane with supplies on the ground
getting those supplies to those in need
is not a given because in between the
runway and the roads there is of course
customs often what happens is that the
national government of the place where
the disasters happened has a way of sort
of relaxing customs efforts for relief
supplies coming in and trying to fast
forward them through but that doesn't
always happen especially with medical
supplies which can include powerful
painkillers that might be particularly
regulated by government and so a lot of
times eight agencies will face a backlog
in their relief supplies coming in as
they get sort of stuck in customs
eventually though once a solid supply
chain is set up responders can actually
get to work
Stephanie and Mike of course work to set
up that field hospital to start treating
all the most severe injuries from the
earthquake while the Harvard
humanitarian initiative where they both
work for doesn't typically itself
actually respond on the ground to
disasters they did exceptionally in this
case and as the literal experts in this
sort of activity they were able to set
up a stellar operation as experts they
knew once again that doctors by
themselves aren't necessarily useful
doctors are useful when placed where
they're needed and so the first step was
to identify what was needed so in the
Haiti response the HHI team identified
one major gap in particular and that was
the lack of rehabilitation resources for
patients that had big operations like
orthopedic operations but had nowhere to
go because there was no place to admit
them and to rehabilitate them therefore
the hospital had its focus and
everything could go from there again
because of the specific nature of the
disaster the team knew that they
couldn't set up their temporary
Hospital just anywhere after an
earthquake in particular when the people
who have been injured in the earthquake
have seen all the buildings around them
fall down they do not want to go into
another building because there are a lot
of aftershocks afterwards and they're
afraid that these buildings might have
been damaged and that they might fall
down and either kill them or cause more
injury and that is a very reasonable
fear and so even though the place where
we were working had buildings that were
very strong and very well able to
sustain all the aftershocks with little
or no damage are the people we were
helping were too afraid to go inside
them the hospital therefore had to be
almost entirely built out of tents
despite the focus on acting as a
rehabilitation centre the hospital did
however still perform surgery and
therefore they needed a super sterile
environment to prevent infection or
contamination during surgery
that's quite tough to create any series
of tents so they used two solutions for
this one the easier way was we had
operating theater trucks so imagine a
big delivery truck and that you can open
the doors and instead of finding boxes
inside you find an alarm or an operating
theater we had a couple of those and
that was very useful because they come
already sealed a lot of our surgeries
though we had to do in what were
classrooms in a school in Haiti and what
we had to do there was to actually tape
up sheets over the windows plastic
sheeting to make sure that no insects or
dust would come from the outside while
we were doing the surgeries so they we
can make it a sterile and safe place to
do them of course the goal of responding
to humanitarian disasters is to get the
humanitarian disaster to end so that
means there also has to be focused on
the exit strategy so when a disaster
happens and we go in and start working
even from the first day we're always
thinking about the day we're going to
leave and so what that means is we do a
number of things right from the start
in Haiti for example we wanted to make
sure that as we were caring for people's
wounds we were teaching the local
doctors and nurses that we were working
with how to do that kind of care if they
weren't already familiar with it so that
when we left they would be able to
easily carry that forward getting to
that finale when the agencies pull out
when a country is back to normal once
life goes on as normal after a disaster
is a delicate science that doesn't
always go to plan no matter how many
frameworks handbooks and guidelines one
has a disaster is a disaster and does
not follow plans the role of all the
planning and preparation though is to
provide structure where there is none
people like Stephanie and Mike spend
their entire career studying and
educating others on this field since
certain help is certainly better than
other help and in a case when the worst
has happened only the best help is
enough working in disaster response
clearly requires that your
problem-solving and critical thinking
skills are quick and accurate those
skills in fact are crucial fundamental
skills for life that can help with
school employment and much more both of
which can be developed with brilliants
courses really all of their courses will
help with problem-solving and critical
thinking skills but a few that can
especially help are their probability
and logic courses luckily both
probability and logic are fascinating
fields and brilliant takes you all the
way from the basic to the advanced in
these fields with their intuitive
superbly designed courses that break
complex topics into manageable intuitive
principles to start developing your
skills you can sign up for brilliant at
brilliant org slash Wendover and if
you're one of the first 200 to do so
you'll get 20% off